une tuerie de masse dans une école un
drame qu'on voit trop souvent dans la
vraie vie
[Musique]
la série bête noire ont fait une fiction
originale et intelligente
le sergent-détective boivent et la
coroner eliane sirois auront la mission
de tenter de comprendre
l'incompréhensible
c'est très facile de juger et de deer ab
sa hausse et intimidations
radicalisation problèmes familiaux
mais qu'est ce qui arrive si c'est plus
nuancé que ceux ci haut pour une seule
et unique raison des pièces d'identité
ont été trouvées dans son pantalon
larmes étaient toujours dans sa main
gauche
ils sont en quête de réponses qui ne
viendront pas qu'est ce qui reste de
panurge est comme ça et que le coupable
et trouver comment les restes des gens
se répare et ce n'est pas seulement de
façon judiciaire on doit se préparer
mais des fois dans la famille dans
l'écosystème chips ou le doute sans rien
enlever à la douleur des familles des
victimes tombées sous les balles
la série bête noire nous force à nous
mettre dans la peau des parents du tueur
ce n'est pas comme des gens vraiment
normaux des parents qui font leurs gros
possible qu'ils sont pas parfaits mais
qui font vraiment ce qu'ils peuvent
des personnes non qualifiées votre
fiston membres vous en pensez quoi un
double deuil une tragédie pour cette
famille qui doit parvenir à se
réconcilier avec ce geste impardonnable
dans salle je pense qu'elle soit le
noyau familial et clape ou soit il se
resserre davantage loin de glorifier le
passage à l'acte est noir nous rappelle
de manière pro talent que la folie
meurtrière détruit des vies et ne laisse
derrière elle que des victimes
c'est un souci de quand même oui de
faire une plongée dans une noirceur mais
de trouver les failles où il va y avoir
de la lumière où on va pouvoir remonter
on va pouvoir respirer une première
incursion la télé pour la réalisatrice
du film
antigone ce fille de ra's qu'ici aussi
s'intéresse à l'adolescence est une
période quand même extrême et c'est
peut-être justement dans le monde adulte
qui parfois bleus prend la légère mais
mais mais lorsqu'on veut l'adolescence
on vit des choses pour la première fois
et à notre échelle lorsqu on les vit à
son immense
[Musique]
bête noire est une catharsis qui fait
réfléchir à découvrir sur siri +6 nabi
alexandre charti hradecka mahb à
montréal